it's true our president takes drugs I'm
taking the hydroxychloroquine right now
yeah I was just waiting to see your eyes
light up what I said this but you know
what I announced his pennis I have been
taking for about a week at me for about
a week and a half at some point every
day I take a pill every day mmm yes the
president did the unthinkable he told
you he was taking a drug prescribed to
him by a White House doctor why cuz he
tells us everything and the media's
addled brains bubbled like cracked eggs
on a hot sidewalk the president united
states said today he is taking a drug to
prevent coronavirus that the FDA warns
is dangerous and study after study now
show is useless against the virus he is
taking an unproven drug that medical
experts warn can have harmful side
effects this is really deadly serious it
is quite dangerous why does he bring up
this hydroxychloroquine I don't even
know that he's really taking it by the
way and that's just what they said
between tokes
now remember Trump hadn't said he was
taking some overpriced exotic root from
the rainforests that Gwyneth Paltrow
claims loosened her chakras
he wasn't licking some toxic acid off an
Amazon Frog rescued from Joe Rogan's
isolation tank no he took a reliable
drug under the best supervision that's
been around a half-century now what
exactly did Chris Cuomo take Cayley
Cuomo mocked the president for this and
interestingly I found this out just
before coming here hydroxychloroquine of
course is an fda-approved medication
with a long proven track record for
safety and it turns out that Chris Cuomo
took a less safe version of it called
quinine which the FDA removed from the
market in 2006 because of its serious
side effects including death so really
interesting to have that criticism of
the president oh she's good but Cuomo
he's a hypocrite eMachine he says don't
break quarantine then he does don't take
risky meds then he does he accuses
people of not taking the virus seriously
and then he does
is it true that this was the swab that
the nurse was actually using on you and
that at first it went into your nose and
disappeared so that in scale this was
the actual swab that was being used to
fit up that double-barrel shotgun that
you have mounted on the front of your
pretty face
he's like a birthday magician on drugs
carrot-top I know you're watching
someone broke into your prop closet call
the cops you know I don't mind mixing
humor with news but do the news first
and the news hasn't been good at least
for the elderly in rest homes who died
by the thousands under Governor Cuomo
and what did the press do they lionized
him in part because of these adorable
CNN routines imagine if I pulled out a
giant swab CNN would condemn my depraved
indifference to death it makes you
wonder when you look at Chris or Don
Lemon what are they news commentary prop
comics at Fox you know what we are I do
commentary Bret Baier does news then we
hot tub like craven beasts but CNN is a
garbage salad dudes doing commentary as
news and so as the media gushed over
Andy they smeared Florida's governor who
had enough got a lot of people in your
profession who wax poetically for weeks
and weeks about our Florida was going to
be just like New York wait two weeks
Florida is going to be next
just like Italy wait two weeks well hell
were eight weeks away from that and it
hasn't happened
I think whatever Trump has is contagious
it's not Corona
but cojones then did you hear Trump
didn't wear his mask briefly in Michigan
some people put it in perspective
except this loon is the president no
longer welcome in Michigan well I will
say speaking on behalf of my department
and my office that's right a president
is like a petulant child who refuses to
follow the rules
he is a redic
this person and I am ashamed to have him
be President of the United States of
America and I hope that the voters of
Michigan will remember this back and
when November comes that he didn't care
enough about their safety he didn't care
about their welfare
nice work crazy lady
now do the guy who brutalized an elderly
person in a Michigan nursing home where
was the care and safety in that yes she
freaks out about the mask but not that
in her own State
nice priorities yet joke it's also funny
watching people like her and reporters
go after Trump for not wearing a mask as
they aren't wearing a mask either
apparently their message is more
important than the president's meanwhile
left-wing writer katha pollitt said this
week she'd vote for Biden even if he ate
babies how does one respond clearly
she's not a vegan shame on her but she
can get away with saying that because
it's not offensive to her peers because
she said baby
she didn't say black baby gay baby trans
baby that would have been too far but
the generic baby that's okay
especially since Planned Parenthood just
got eighty million from the Paycheck
protection plan which was to aid small
businesses during the pandemic how is
America's largest abortion business
small I get it their victims are so is
the media truly concerned about Trump's
health no it's just that the media loves
knowing things you don't it validates
the superiority necessary for their
insecure elite class it's why they faint
at the thought of taking an
anti-malarial pill but it's shrooms by
the pound it's why they think nuclear
power is evil but crystal healing rules
they need to be first and once something
cool becomes popular they hate it the
media loves to boast about the hot
Broadway play you can't get tickets to
for a year they tried to out Hamilton
each other oh did you get tickets yet
yeah they're so expensive we got ours
through a friend of a friend this
special class loves the free stuff the
secret stuff the stuff they can get
illegally and they'll never share it
with you but Trump's the opposite if he
likes something he'll tell you about it
it's not like he's above you and that's
weird now the jury's out on this drugs
seems useless at the end stage but maybe
maybe helpful in the early phase it's a
line of defense that you assess with
your daughter
idiots like me you can't buy it at the
GNC it's prescribed again by a doctor
not a politician
no wonder Nancy's tit he's our president
and I would rather he not be taking
something that has not been approved by
the scientists especially in his age
group and in his shall we say weight
group but it is morbidly obese they say
that's a pretty good joke now to Jerry
Nadler or Stacy Keach just kidding you
can only fat shame some people but she's
got game and Joe Biden could learn from
her Nancy I need new nicknames for the
president
I like President Tweety because you know
the bird they're both Orange how about
morbidly obese yeah no no we need more
hyphens in their racist philandering
still do short I like my insults long
like a Hannity monologue
how about degenerate and presidential
obese lying Russian racist a pony
soldier bony solder and hit some makes
the hair on my legs stand up I'm gonna
reach in and touch it come on real quick
I'll close my eyes I I'm in San
Francisco oh love San Fran and that
golden steak bridge hold on oh gotta go
that's hunter but Nana shouldn't be
nailing Trump for managing its own
health unless she's got better info than
his doc and it's cute how our vein over
classes go after a person taking a legal
drug during a pandemic what would happen
if Trump said he loved Botox and
adderall the entire press would have to
quit both they'd get nothing done but
the crying the good news we believe life
is good
good again cases are dramatically
declining and a new Gallup poll shows
people are happier more than a month ago
they sense good things and it ain't a
wrinkle cream this perspective diverges
from the misery media who see grim
horizons beyond their stretched faces we
know we've dumped great but we are done
hiding and we're done leaving it to the
media in their lies it's time to get up
go outside and get to work we can do
this we already have it's pretty simple
wash your hands a lot put on a mask a
lot don't hug strangers protect the
elderly and get to work
unless you're the media maybe you should
sit this one out you've done enough
damage have you thought about a broccoli
enema I know someone who knows someone
who could squeeze you in